you want to save my soul I'm telling you
girl I sold mine
to the devil
you know who I am which is a problem
problem that has to go away
that
how generally works in our department
we'll get an outline when we get the
first scrip we then go through it and we
basically notate all of the areas that
very clearly
screams visual effects and then I go
through it and spend a few days where
I'm actually going through every scene
and I technically break down how we're
gonna shoot it jedd basically called me
I said hey we're gonna be a ghostwriter
I mean it's a huge IP to get on a show
like this and being at ten o'clock and
being able to do all the extra things
that I hope we're gonna get to do and
the tone you know a little darker but
still fun it's gonna be great so you've
got the devil inside you too
technically I designed a hood that has
LEDs on it it's powered up and has a
flicker it actually couldn't adjust
different color temperatures so we have
something yellow that actually works
very nicely and because a flicker saleem
so the jacket has is lit up because it
would be lit up if you were a light
source so then we open it up more so I
get more of Gabe's face and I have
tracking markers on there and really
it's about trying to get Gabe's emotions
what he's sort of expressing through his
face and apply some of that feel I or
'''but sand all that kind of bit of
business to me it was about having a
character that the audience can actually
connect to can actually you know relate
to can feel and so therefore it became
about what kind of things can I add into
this like that like the little burning
coal eyes the fact of the eye orbits you
know squash and stretch for expression
the fact that this area here essentially
works like exhaust pipes
we started using motion capture last
season a little bit on season 2 as well
we ended up cyber scanning game and
that's what we take him and we make a
digital representation of him that's a
3d character the beautiful thing about
motion capture is is that if you're an
animator trying to just animate a
digital double and getting all the
nuances to weight shifts the little
micro movements it's very hard to sort
of make that come through on just a
typical character animation so the
motion capture enables you to capture
all of that stuff so anyways yeah so
that's that's sort of the process with
visual effects and with Ghost Rider and
all that we're doing this season hey
youtubers it's Charlie so new Ghost
Rider trailer where he named drops the
devil so very important let's break it
down so the big thing here is that
episode 2 is called meet the new boss
now the a story is really like
introducing the new director of shield
the Jason O'Mara character but I think
like the B meaning because we have all
this Ghost Rider footage is that you're
gonna learn about the new boss of the
streets as well as ghost riders boss
like the ghost rider persona or maybe
even Mephisto because like I talked
about Mephisto in my Marvel phase 4
video yesterday because the actor who
plays Ghost Rider is talking about him
Mephisto appeared in the Ghost Rider
movie he's important for a number of big
Marvel Avengers stories including the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline so
everybody's just wondering what Mephisto
status is in the MCU and even though
they don't say a whole lot
Marvel actually does know each exact
character that they're capable of doing
in their movies the Russo said that like
when they were plotting out infinity war
they had boards on all the walls of this
specific room with people that were
alive and people that were dead current
status of everybody from like the most
minor of characters like Galaga man from
the first Avengers film all the way up
to Thanos and even the new big a-list
characters that they have not rolled out
yet like Captain Marvel so like we're
all wondering about Mephisto Marvel
knows but they usually like to be quiet
about stuff like this and just let
people speculate just to err on the side
of caution like usually they could be
more effective when
don't confirm or deny things like just
they just kind of like the fandom just
have fun with it it remains to be seen
whether or not Mephisto makes his
presence known
during agents of shield but the way
Ghost Rider talks about it in this
footage he talks about selling his soul
to the devil that's actually a bit of a
twist on his comic book origin story so
one either they're changing his comic
book story just a little bit and like
you know he ends up dying in a street
race to try and raise money for his
brothers condition to help support his
brother who's you know in the wheelchair
or two he only thinks he sold his soul
to the devil and it's like a twist and
like the person he sold his soul to is
somebody different so just remains to be
seen but the whole idea of episode two
is just showing you the characters that
were only mentioned in the first episode
so it's like you know pulling the
curtain back a little bit more so on the
lighter side of things one I'm hoping
that we find out the name of the new
director of shield like is he gonna be
the Jim Hammond original Human Torch and
two on the darker side of things learn a
little bit more about what the TV show
is doing with this version of Ghost
Rider because just like the Marvel
movies and the Netflix series change
little things about comic book
backstories like the idea with the
Mandarin and Iron Man 3 like the real
Mandarin is out there somewhere so even
if they don't go with Mephisto on agents
of shield is the origin of this Ghost
Rider which wasn't necessarily the way
it happened in the comics that doesn't
mean that Mephisto is not inside the MCU
but it seems like everybody's really
jazzed up about Ghost Rider it's amazing
how much a flaming skull with good
special effects can turn people around
like before the season came out everyone
was kind of 50/50 on this version of
Ghost Rider look like oh you know Johnny
Blaze Danny ketch they're my favorite
coast rider but then we see diego luna
who's the actor that's playing Ghost
Rider that's his name in real life and
his rides in fast and furious style like
a boss and I was like oh yeah this is
awesome this is gonna be a lot of fun
but let me know in the comments do you
guys think that they'll be like super
accurate to this version of Ghost Rider
in the comics or do you think they'll
roll big and try to tease Mephisto now
I'm not expecting the actual devil to
make an appearance any time soon you
know this is all about introducing the
Ghost Rider character it's all about his
arc learning about his family why he
became Ghost Rider with his shield gonna
do it
him because he's something way beyond
way more powerful than the Inhumans they
face so far with me you know maybe the
exception of hive just because of the
way his power worked but you know for
now it seems like Ghost Rider mostly
going to be an antagonist until
something worse comes along which is
really like where this mystery spirit
comes in which doesn't really appear in
the trailer so I don't know how big it's
gonna be in Episode two but just look
out for some of the fun that they have
with making you think that there's
conflict inside of each of these groups
like Ghost Rider conflict even though we
know he's plugin end up being a good
character in conflict with the new
director who actually seems like a
really good person who's just a super
hard-ass but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Booya awesome
name I always liked names the double as
expressions you win a gift certificate
for the Captain America Civil War
blu-ray just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details so there
isn't a whole bunch of crazy Marvel news
today so I'm probably gonna be doing DC
later tonight but the rumored spider-man
Home Coming trailer is still a couple
weeks away haven't heard any crazy news
about that recently but there is some
mary-jane stuff so I might do a new
spider-man homecoming video this weekend
but if you have any Marvel video
requests just leave them in the comments
below and be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's been reports that there's gonna
be a bunch of new Doctor Strange footage
next week so there should be some cool
Marvel stuff dropping really soon
besides the agents of shield and Luke
Cage stuff that's happening next week
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that Ghost Rider
Episode one video and you can click here
to learn all about Mephisto Dormammu and
Marvel phase four thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight